et puis cette autre manifestation à
paris des collectifs et des associations
d'habitants qui se sont rassemblés dans
le 19e arrondissement ils réclament
plutôt que des salles de shoot nous
présent charge sanitaire digne et des
soins appropriés pour les toxicomanes à
l'écart des lieux habités il estime
avoir été abandonnés par les pouvoirs
publics ou ce qu'on souhaiterait c'était
une prise en charge sanitaire de ces
personnes parce qu'elles ont besoin
d'être aidés d'être hébergés là les
déplacer d'un quartier à l'autre comme
c'est le cas depuis la plaine des cracks
depuis stalingrad puis elle maintenant
depuis la villette c'est juste déplacer
le problème mais il n'ya porter aucune
solution voilà en fait on estime qu'en
tant rivera dans tout paris on a droit à
la sécurité à la sérénité on a droit
d'élever nos enfants dans la
tranquillité donc je pense que la patate
chaude que tout le monde se refile ça
suffit il est temps de faire un plan non
pas local ni régionales on veut un plan
national on est là parce que justement
vous de montrer qu'on n'est pas du tout
d'accord si vous voulez nous nous sommes
pour l'instant la seule salle de shoot
qui a été créée il ya maintenant cinq
ans et on se mobilise depuis cinq ans
pour que cette salle de shoot ne soit
plus dans une zone habitée avec les gens
de tous âges et surtout des enfants
aussi donc on voudrait que si il devait
y avoir salles de consommation qu'elle
ne soit pas dans une zone habitée
[Musique]